So going back to our original problem, if we want to rationalize this
denominator we can actually use the conjugate. We multiply the denominator and
the numerator by the same amount. So that way we multiply by 1. We know we can
multiply by the conjugate since if we multiply these two expressions together
we'll wind up with a number in our denominator, with no radical. We'll simply
have a squared minus b squared, which would be 7 minus 5. A squared is 7, and b
squared is 5. We multiply each of these radicals by 4, to get this numerator.
Next we simplify our denominator to get 2. If we leave the 4 outside of these
two radicals then we can simplify a common factor of 2 in our numerator and
denominator. So our denominator simplifies to 1, leaving us with 2 root 7 plus
2 root 5. Notice that we rationalized our denominator. We had something that
contained radicals to something that turned into 1. Now not every time our
denominator will be so nice. Sometimes we'll just have a number down here. In
this case our denmoinator was 1, but we know that's not always the case.